simplify the rational expression and
state the domain so once again we have a
a trinomial over trinomial to see if we
can simplify we need to factor both of
them and that's also going to help us
figure out the domain the domain is
essentially figuring out all of the
valid X's that we can put into this
expression and not get something that's
undefined so let's factor the numerator
and the denominator so let's start with
the numerator let's start with the
numerator there and since we have a 2
out front since we have a 2 out front
factoring by grouping will probably be
the best way to go so let's just rewrite
it here I'm just working on the
numerator right now - x squared plus 13x
plus 20 so we need to find two numbers a
and B that if I multiply them a times B
needs to be equal to let me write it
over here on the right a times B needs
to be equal to 2 times 20 so it has to
be equal to positive 40 and then a plus
B has to be equal to 13 and the numbers
that jump out at me immediately are five
and eight alright five times eight is
forty five plus eight is 13 so we can
break this 13 X into a 5x and an 8x and
so we can rewrite this as 2x squared and
it will break up the 13 X into and I'm
going to write the 8x first I'm going to
write 8x plus 5x and the reason why I
wrote the 8x first is because the eight
shares common factors with the two so
maybe we can factor out a 2x here it'll
simplify a little bit five shares
factors with the 20 so let's see where
this goes and then we finally have a
plus 20 here and now we can group them
that's the whole point of factoring by
grouping so you group these first two
characters right here let's factor out a
2x so this would become 2x times well 2x
squared divided by 2x is just going to
be X 8x divided by 2x is going to be
plus 4 and then let's factor let's
factor out these or let's group these
two characters and if we factor out a 5
what do we get we get plus 5 Plus 5
times
X + 4 5 x divided by 5 is X 20 divided
by 5 is 4 and we have an x + 4 in both
cases so we can factor that out right we
have x + 4 x 2 terms we could
undistribute it so this thing this thing
over here will be x + 4 times x let me
do that same color - x + 5 - x + 5 and
we factored this numerator expression
right there now let's do the same thing
with the denominator expression I'll do
that in a different let me see I want to
run out of color so the denominator
right over here let's do the same
exercise with it so we have 2x squared +
17 x + 30 let's look for an A and a B
when I multiply them I get 2 times 30
which is 60 and a plus a B when I add
them I get 17 and once again let's see 5
and 12 seem to work so let's split this
up let's split this up into 2 x squared
so we're going to split up the 17 X into
a into a what was it 12 X + a 5 X right
that adds up to 17 X and when you
multiply 12 times 5 you get 60 and then
plus 30 plus 30 and then on this first
group right here this first group right
here we can factor out a 2x so if you
factor out a 2x you get 2x times X plus
6 and in that second group in that
second group we can factor out a 5 so
you get plus 5 times X plus 6 and now we
can factor out an X plus 6 and we get we
get x + 6 x times 2x plus 5 2x plus 5 so
we've now factored the numerator the
denominator let's rewrite both of these
expressions or write this entire
rational expression with the numerator
and the denominator factored so the
numerator so this is going to be equal
to X plus 4 times 2x plus 5 we figure
that out right there and then the
denominator the denominator is X plus 6
times 2x plus 5 now you might already
might already jump out at you that you
have a 2x plus 5 of the numerator in the
denominator we can cancel them out and
we will cancel them out but before we do
that let's work on the second part of
this question state the domain so what
are the valid x-values that we could put
in here or I get some a more interesting
question what are the x-values that will
make this this rational expression
undefined
what's the x-values that will make the
denominator equal to 0 and when will the
denominator equal to 0 well either when
X plus 6 is equal to 0 or when 2x plus 5
is equal to 0
and we could just solve for X here
subtract 6 from both sides you get X is
equal to negative 6
and if you subtract 5 from both sides
you get 2x is equal to negative 5 divide
both sides by 2 you get X is equal to
negative 5 halves so if X so we could
say that the domain let me write this
over here the domain is all real numbers
all real numbers other than or except
except X is equal to negative 6 and X is
equal to negative 5 halves and the
reason why we have to exclude those is
those would make this denominator either
way you're right it's going to make the
denominator equal to zero and it would
make the entire rational expression
undefined so we've stated the domain now
let's just simplify the rational
expression we've already said that X
cannot be equal to negative 5 halves or
negative 6 so let's just divide the
numerator in the denominator by 2x plus
5 or just look at the 2x plus 5 we know
that 2x plus five won't be 0 because x
won't be equal to negative 5 halves so
we can cancel those out and the
simplified rational expression is just X
plus 4 over X
+6